bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord sur cette
plainte des étudiants en bts contre jean
michel blanquer
qu'en pensez vous en réalité qu'est ce
que les étudiants dénoncent ils
dénoncent l'amateurisme la déconnexion
et l'incompétence totale de ce
gouvernement dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire
ce que nous à l'union dénonce depuis
maintenant et c'est malheureux de le
dire le début de la crise c'est-à-dire
depuis un an et demi quand lors du
premier confinement nous demandions au
gouvernement aux ministres de
l'éducation nationale et la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de préparer la
rentrée 2000 va pas qu'on savait
stratégique puisque les établissements
avaient été fermés durant une une longue
période de temps
quand nous demandions des examens bien
construit et bien organisés au premier
semestre pour sanctionner le travail de
ses étudiants en décembre on a bien
compris que ce n'était pas l'objectif du
gouvernement
et quand dans ce mois même mois de
décembre la ministre nous annonce un
retour en présentiel au mois de janvier
et que la première conférence de presse
de notre cher premier ministre jean
castex et dire ne mentionne pas une
seule fois le mot étudiants et ne
mentionne même pas une seule fois le la
jeunesse de france
eh bien on se rend bien compte que ce
n'est pas une priorité que la jeunesse
est que les étudiants n'est pas une
priorité pour le gouvernement est en
fête
et encore une fois qu'est ce que dénonce
et étudiants tout simplement ils
dénoncent les annonces à la petite
semaine
deux de ces deux de ses ministres qui ne
comprennent pas la détresse des
étudiants est aujourd'hui on se rend
bien compte que même et on va en parler
j'espère sur l'organisation de ce second
semestre ses examens nombreux sont les
étudiants et et ne parlons pas seulement
du bts nombreux sont les étudiants qui
ne savent toujours pas comment ils
passeront leurs examens en distance yens
ou en présentiel
telle est la question mais c'est aussi
compliqué pour le gouvernement lorsqu'il
n'y a pas de présentiel et bien ça ne
fait pas l'unanimité quand il ya
justement des présentiel
il ya encore il n'ya pas de satisfaction
comment vous interprétez le fond
justement de cette décision de jean
michel blanquer
concernant ces étudiants en bts marne le
maintenir leurs examens en présentiel
mais aujourd'hui encore une fois on
demande au ministre de tout simplement
comprendre l'importance de la détresse
de ces étudiants et l'importance de
l'incompréhension que la compréhension
qu'ils ont de leur gestion de la crise
cette gestion qui est catastrophique
disons le aujourd'hui toutes les
problématiques liées à cela et on est on
entendait le ministre en parler sur la
valeur du diplôme sur l'insertion
professionnelle sur la réussite de ses
étudiants on n'a pas l'impression que ce
soit la priorité du gouvernement quand
on voit les chiffres ils sont alarmants
quand on voit que le taux de 2,2 de
réorientation des étudiants a augmenté
de 5% cela prouve bien d'une que le
diplôme du bac a été malheureusement
bien dégradée l'année dernière et qu'il
y a eu beaucoup trop d'étudiants qui
sont rentrés dans cet ordre
d'enseignement supérieur et ce nombre
est largement trop trop trop élevé quand
on voit que sur toute l'année 2020 près
de 55 % des diplômés de master 2 c'est à
dire 50 d'enseignement supérieur n'ont
pas trouvé de boulot et non pas trouvé
ne se sont pas inséré
professionnellement justement au bout de
six mois on voit bien qu'il ya des
réelles problématiques que le
gouvernement ne prend pas compte et nous
on l'a fait on a fait le travail
parlementaire pour lutter contre la
précarité est une rente annuelle des
propositions de loi sont déposées en ce
moment-même sénat notamment et que
faut-il faire il faut annuler les
examens présentiel c'est réaliste il il
faut comprendre d'une la détresse des
étudiants et comprendre que leur
insertion professionnelle est en jeu et
quand on voit que les étudiants
n'arrivent pas à voir plus loin que leur
bout de leur nez
il faut comprendre que ces étudiants
veulent simplement
appréhender leur avenir et non demande
clairement au ministre vous me demandez
vous posez la question demande
clairement ministre il y à ce sujet des
examens mais il y a aussi clairement le
sujet de la rentrée prochaine
et comme nous l'avions fait lors du
premier conflit en demander nous
demandons aujourd'hui au ministère de
comprendre que la rentrée prochaine va
être très stratégique et qu'il va
falloir la faire en présentiel donc mais
justement vous évoquez la dévalorisation
du diplôme pour éviter d'aller jusque là
cette conséquence qui est dramatique
pour les étudiants et leur avenir
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et bien
clairement c'est ce qu'on demande depuis
maintenant janvier puisqu'on avions nous
avions nous nous étions rendus compte
que c'était en janvier qu'on a vu que
nous avons été déçus tout simplement sur
le retour en présentiel
il faut il faut un retour présentiel
avec en fait il faut écouter les vous
savez les présidents d'université qui
sont sur le terrain et qui connaissent
la réalité du terrain et quand vous avez
l'ensemble des présidents ou en tout cas
l'immense majorité des présidents
d'université qui vous disent que et
qu'il le dise le ministère que près de
preuve que la capacité d'accueil pleut
la jauge d'accueil qui est aujourd'hui
bloqué à 20% peut être augmenté à 50 %
eh bien il faut écouter et comme nous
nous nous voyons la ministre vidal se
rendre compte seulement maintenant que
effectivement cette jauge des 50% des
capacités d'accueil peuvent être
attendre dans les conditions sanitaires
comme le dit les présidents d'université
comme demande lui nie depuis très
longtemps depuis maintenant quelques
mois
et bien le dit que on va le faire pour
me mets mi juin et madame la ministre
mais mais mi juin
vous êtes complètement déconnecté de la
réalité il n'y a plus aucun étudiants
sur les campus
donc aujourd'hui on se rend encore une
fois compte que le gouvernement que ça
soit la ministre vidalou houleux où
monsieur bleu blanc coeur qu'ils sont
déconnectés de la réalité et quand on
voit une madame vidal qui nous dit que
la jauge des 50% va enfin être atteinte
mais pour seulement mi mai et mi juin
eh bien on voit bien qu'elle est
complètement déconnecté et que
maintenant la grande question c'est la
rentrée prochaine et qu'il faut s'y
préparer dès maintenant et en plus du
risque de contamination l'avocat du
collectif 1 d'étudiants qui portent
plainte m di vizio pointe une fatigue
morale
une détresse chez ces jeunes est ce que
vous vous avez le sentiment qu'ils sont
entendus que le ministère de l'éducation
prend suffisamment en compte ce facteur
non absolument pas absolument pas je je
je je pense que et puis je les dis il ya
il y à un moment où vous savez quand il
y à cet étudiant sur dix qui ont qui se
sentent qu'ils sentent leur santé
mentale dégradé quand vous avez près
d'un quart des étudiants qui ont déjà eu
des pensées suicidaires et tout cela lié
au décrochage bien évidemment vous savez
quand madame vidal se targue de des
statistiques de 90% de taux de présence
aux examens pour le premier semestre
il faut bien que madame vidal
comprennent que rendre une copie blanche
ce n'est pas une preuve de réussite est
un gage de réussite c'est à dire que
dans ces 90 % qu'elle de ce fameux
chiffres qu'elle qu'elle se vante de de
dire il y a des copies blanche est donc
ce n'est absolument pas une réussite
et d'ailleurs on nous demandons toujours
à la ministre le taux de réussite qu'il
faudrait les statistiques de taux de
réussite qu'il faudrait avoir pour ses
premiers semaine pour bien comprendre
que le distanti elle est bien aggrave la
qualité de notre formation dégrade la
valeur de notre diplôme et amène au
décrochage qui malheureusement ensuite
tout est lié
dégrade aussi l'insertion
professionnelle défavorise la station
professionnels de tous nos jeunes
donc il y a vraiment tous ces objectifs
là toutes ces statistiques malheureuse
là qu'il faut qu'il faut prendre en
compte et avoir encore une fois l'idée
de la rentrée prochaine en ligne 2 en
ligne de mire et très bien essayé de la
présenter que demandez-vous en vue de la
rentrée prochaine rapidement et bien
tout ça tout simplement une rentrée en
présentiel dans les conditions
sanitaires mais une rentrée en
présentiel ou les étudiants pourront
retrouver les bancs de leurs de leurs
facultés retrouver le lien social qui
leur a tant manqué depuis depuis
maintenant plus d'un an et pouvoir tout
simplement vie
retrouvez aussi les jobs les stages
qu'ils avaient perdue depuis depuis un
an et demi est tout simplement vivre
leur vie étudiante comme il l'avait
comme il l'avait souhaité vous savez que
ça soit les premières années où les
deuxièmes années il faut bien comprendre
que tous les élans et les l2 et les
premières et l'ensemble des 1er et 2e
dan et de l'ensemble de l'enseignement
supérieur français n'ont pas connu une
année universitaire normal complète et
donc aujourd'hui il faut clairement
quand on nous parle d'un impact de la
crise sanitaire qui vont qui va perdurer
et bien là nous ont dit que les
étudiants ne vont pas perdurer comme ça
longtemps et donc que la rentrée
universitaire 2021 va être largement
stratégique et que le ministère doit s'y
préparer dès maintenant pour qu'elle se
fasse au maximum en présentiel une
rentrée universitaire qui sera
probablement conditionné par l'avancé
donc de la campagne vaccinale merci à
vous jacques smith je rappelle que vous
êtes délégué de l'union nationale inter
universitaire